[Musica]
ciao
aiuto
[Musica]
gelati
no questo è troppo buono lo voglio per
forza
sì sì sì sì allora prendo il 11 il 12
se non c'hanno il 12 prendo il 9 poi
voglio il 14 il centro 17 519 signora
dei gelati visivamente la tv è il 119
buongiorno signor giro taglio allora
duca vorrei il numero 157 347 punti 5 14
nobili tutela b il camioncino dei gelati
[Musica]
sempre
vabbè
devo andare a salvarlo
[Musica]
la mappa
gelateria strana c'è nessuno ei
[Musica]
se qualcuno nessuno
che cosa è successo
ho rotto solo taglio cattivo ice cream
si è iscritto ho visto primati ha
congelato o congelato ma voglio che ti
vuole trasformare in un gelato o no io
lo voglio con toro il gelato non
diventare tratti sembra il momento di
dire queste protesi come faccia a
liberarti devi trovare tutti gli effetti
ed enti che sono sparsi in giro e poi
riuscirò a liberarti devi trovare la
chiave per aprirmi da cui mi scongiurò
armi non posso offrirti d'acqua
direttamente ma servono aiuto
ok allora tu aspetta qua devi essere
impaziente però ok
pensavo di andare in spiaggia come in
spiaggia ma si sono succedute voleva
faccia talvolta barbie da qui hai
ragione voi che chiudo la porta da solo
porta ferro lascia la porta aperta sia
troppo di caldo magari magari farò del
mio meglio trovare sugli oggetti per
riuscire a portare un piatto di minestra
così di gas caldo
ok vado subito importante e cercherò di
trovare tutto
ok ragazzi
il primo oggetto da trovare e la
cassetta degli attrezzi berlino
devi aiutarmi con il tuo fiuto a trovare
questo oggetto con il tuo fiuto
infallibile
cerchiamo la cassetta degli attrezzi
assieme ma non dobbiamo essere presi da
ice cream road
altrimenti game over se questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche ice scream 2 nella realtà e la
partita pro ti mandiamo vetrino sta
fiutando qualcosa seguiamolo dove questo
nella cassetta degli attrezzi aiuto per
cercarla aiuterà mi sta portando da
qualche parte vediamo perché ci sono dei
po corta ma chi è buttato di pop corn
scommetto che è stato vitale berlino no
non mangiare adesso berlino di vita che
mi trovare la cassetta degli attrezzi ti
prego dobbiamo svegliarci o no
eccolo ma proprio quando portò di me
dietro questo pianeta
alla pietro
stanno bene
allora perché mi sta guardando tutto
questo è il mio giudizio disposto da qui
ma aspetto momento che cos'è questa è
una cosa sì l'ho trovato
ok sono riuscita al seminario devo
riuscire entrare dentro casa
nerino sta attento road qua vicino
avevo la cassetta degli attrezzi w al
progetto andiamo
se siamo riusciti a seminare andiamo ora
proviamo ad aprirlo vediamo cosa c'è
dentro non siano moltissimi bloccato
devo trovare un altro oggetto per
riaprire la cassetta degli attrezzi
l'altro oggetto è il cacciavite
[Musica]
ok c'è mancato poco
la cassetta degli attrezzi non si apre
dobbiamo trovare il cacciavite per
aprirla so cosa si sarà detta dobbiamo
sbrigarci per salvare evitare prima che
venga trasformato in un bagno alle
noccioline o al pistacchio
ce ne sono
mi sembra che ci siano
[Musica]
siamo stati molto fortunati a trovare la
cassetta degli attrezzi ma il cacciavite
più piccolo non so se riusciremo a
trovarlo qualcosa mi dice che potrebbe
essere dentro la gelateria di ice scream
proviamo a dare un'occhiata sperando che
lui non sia dentro
non va
vediamo
non mi sembra tv per niente dentro
no
un sacco di paura che spunti fuori
all'improvviso magari magari qua nella
cabina guidatore proviamo ad aprile il
volante mi sembra di vedere niente
eccolo ragazze il cacciavite
non ci sono riuscito a trovarlo ok
abbiamo adesso torniamo dentro
mi sembrava strano che non si fosse
fatto vedere tutto questo tempo molto
ferran ha scosso stata ti ho rubato il
cacciavite dovevano creato aiuto capiamo
non penso che riesca ad aprire le porte
vogliamo no ma letizia scoprire le forze
devo sbrigarmi prima che è finito cosa
devo fare adesso
forse devo aprire la cassetta che cosa
offrirà questa chiave il numero 5 cosa
vorrei dire quindi forse questo è
l'ultimo oggetto sarà sei l'ultimo
oggetto aprirà la coppia dobbiamo subito
andare ad aprirlo allora ecco lì che mi
sta guardando
per fortuna non ha fatto niente a
merlino
per fortuna non è ghiacciato berlino ma
che fa merlino dove stai andando non si
deve avvicinare lui sta controllando la
sua gelateria oppure me sta aspettando
no no come faccio adesso vestire
previsto proprio spettacoli sarà
impossibile prevedere il camper non fa
niente
dobbiamo provarci lo stesso per evitare
che è vitale si trasformi in un cornetto
alla crema
scherzavo
se n'è andato
via libera
voto 6
bene o no
marino
entrare tutti
aiuto
bravo bambino bravo berlino destroy l'ho
scelto io entro club e berlino no
in queste righe quote vi distrarlo ok ho
chiuso la porta così rod non può salire
forse lo spero dove vedo più marino il
ferro
pollo ora che spunti fuori
all'improvviso
devo nascondere altrimenti cassero anche
me
ecco che paura o no vai via
ok
apriamo vitale speriamo che non si sia
già trasformazioni un gelato io sono
bravo
per fortuna è trasformato in un gelato
ho trovato la chiave spero che sia
quella giusta
dentro questa chiave forse va qua qua
proviamo funziona non lo so andiamo
andiamo ma non per niente più ascoltami
decine anche contento perché è successo
perché scrive che guarda qualche poster
ott
quindi sappiamo subito andiamo andiamo
prima di arrivi qua fuori trova qua
dentro ci prenderà entrambi ska più
andiamo
sbrigati
è entrato nella sua gelateria forse sta
andando via
speriamo quindi vuol dire che abbiamo
vinto da charlie ma ci sono riuscito a
prendere nessun gelate ma insomma
[Musica]
soc
questa sera
[Musica]
ice cream e laggiù vi sta aspettando ice
cream se questo video raggiunge i 30
mila mi piace ci sarà un nuovo video con
ice cream compresa questa volta solo una
volta avrò perso la challenger perché
sapete che se ice cream ti prende ti
congela etica dentro una gabbia quindi
non potrò più fare lo slam sicuramente
dentro una gabbia che pronti
mettetevi comodi prendi tipo corna e
iniziamo la nostra ricerca stanno
uscendo dal campo lo vedete
quelli che mi aspetta
vai merino vai a prenderlo maledizione
con faccia a cercarvi irredentista in sé
lì che mi aspetta che fa merlino
ok si sta allontanando avviciniamoci
piano piano
[Musica]
forse è rientrato dentro
sono sicura che gli ingredienti sono
dentro il suo camioncino dei gelati
purtroppo
marino vedere se c'è qualcosa quadretto
avvicinato non so come ma sono riuscita
a recuperare alla south ora era dentro
al suo camioncino dei gelati proprio
all'entrata è ancora lì forse quando mi
verrebbero
ok
sta andando via
dobbiamo anche controllare ogni minimo
amicolo perché gli ingredienti
potrebbero essere ovunque tipo
potrebbero essere forse potrà essere a
fianco a me ma ho devo dire che questa
challenge sta andando su per bene per
ora anche se il nemico questa volta è
molto cattivo è molto più difficile
sconfiggerlo
mi sembra che ci sia nessuno sento
niente però devo dire che questi gelati
sembrano super buoni guardate ne vorrei
davvero uno adesso chissà se road mangia
davvero i gelati o trasforma solo le
persone in gelati
lui è cattivo perché trasforma le
quindi vuol dire che tutti questi celati
in realtà prima erano delle persone
la voglio più mangiare come si apre è
molto grande e qui sento dei rumori
povere che si stia avvicinando forse con
questa mappa riuscirò a trovare gli
ingredienti
forse devo controllarla bene
a mio avviso per fortuna devo sbrigarmi
devo cercarlo speriamo tutti i cassetti
niente
c'è qualcosa ci sono delle padelle per
cucinare i gelati soluzione per lei si è
accorto di chiudere la porta a porta
come si chiude approvato coprire la
porta devo tener la chiesa è molto più
forte di me non pensa di riuscire a
tenere la porta chiesa a lungo fermo 1
posto entra doveri che faccio
quando qua dietro
per come ragiono filate
non mi ha visto e sta tornando indietro
ha chiuso la porta
per fortuna mi sono nascosta dobbiamo
scappare
a meno che non mi nascondo qua sopra e
questo sorta di lettino ripostiglio ma
aspettiamo quindi carbonato
io ho trovato due cose qua dentro
approfittiamo per posto che sia vita non
riescono aprirla solo chiusa a chiave
non so se mi ha visto per fortuna è
molto lento non riesci a prendermi bene
posso anche passeggiare tanto il super
lento
c'è qualcosa di strano perché è rimasta
immobile
va beh non c'è tempo adesso per capire
che cosa sta tramando abbiamo il
bicarbonato alla ciò crea la spatola è
la soluzione per letti quindi sapete
cosa vuol dire che manca solo una cosa
fondamentale la colla ave ragazzi siamo
tornati fuori
ho come l'impressione che la colla sia
dentro al camioncino dei gelati di roth
se fosse qua fuori sarebbe troppo facile
quindi purtroppo dovremo risalire però
non vedo rotta
quindi sicuramente là dentro se non equa
in giro che cammina sarà là dentro la
quindi siamo molto attenti e là dentro
che fa l'immobile questa che è la corda
forse potrei fare questa corda come
potrei farla mi è venuta un'idea
attiriamo rotte in una trappola e le
chiamo lo è il signor gelataio o un
gelato buonissimo per te o no aspetta
non ho pensato bene questa cosa
come faccio a legarlo una volta che si
avvicina e aspetta devo andare a
prendere questa genere più non se lo si
aspetti un momento qui fermo vado a
prenderla mia vista
signor gelataio ice cream è un qui il
gelato e proprio qua vicino questo
albero guarda e qua dentro
e proprio quarda preso cofattore ti
leggo a questo passerà così non potrà
più scappare
svegliamoci prima che riesca a liberarsi
non ci riesco a credere che esiste non
riuscita anche se berlino era un po in
mezzo alle scatole però alla fine ci
sono riuscita h m o no guardate si è già
legato
[Musica]
no
proviamo ad offrire qua forse la scuola
si vuole una chiave maledizione si vuole
la chiave sia portarla chiave anche qua
questo è aperto
basta iniziati benzina forse il
quartetto forse la con acqua stanza di
benzina
questa voce per trovato la colla ma in
vuota allora per forza risalire la sopra
chiusa la porta anche se non durerà a
lungo
come si chiudeva a chiave sbrighiamoci
da un lato provata ho trovato la colla
ragazzi ora devo solo scappare per farlo
online
come è andato via perché mi devo cercare
qualcosa per difendermi un estintore
potrebbe funzionare
non lo so pesa un sacco non so se può
funzionare per difendermi testa
tantissimo quindi riuscire a difendermi
con questo
peccati questo
e fifa scappiamo rimasto paralizzato
scappiamo prima che svanisca l'affetto
non la colla dove l'ho messa però che
l'effetto dell'estintore duri molto e
sarà qualcosa che c'era nel camper e la
corda che si illumina io ed è verde
gialla
soluzioni il carbonato becchiamoci
non mi sembra di sentire niente forse
ancora paralizzato dall'istinto e
mescoliamo tutto
guardate che bello
nuovo questo lei non è ancora pronto
eccolo qua e più belle flame
ce l'abbiamo fatta questa volta con uno
slam che si illumina al buio è stato
difficile con road ma alla fine ce
l'abbiamo fatta guardi che meglio questo
slam
[Musica]
novità renon ad ammazzarlo l'ha mangiato
vieni merlino nuove operazioni di
salvataggio
questa volta dovremo salvare vitale
andiamo
il primo oggetto da trovare e la chiave
per aprire la porta principale quindi
sbrighiamoci cerchiamo la chiave
mi raccomando se non avete ancora
lasciato un mi piace e lasciate un bel
mi piace su questo video se questo video
raggiunge i 40 mila mi piace ci sarà il
quarto episodio di ice cream prot
e se ancora non mi seguite su instagram
andati a seguirmi il nome di the stories
ma ora non perdiamo tempo cerchiamo
subito le chiavi
abbiamo subito prova per rinviare
[Musica]
perfetto e ora dove sarà rotta dobbiamo
rubargli la mappa dalle tasche ce la
faremo
eccolo nella giunchi dobbiamo prendere
la mappa dalla sua testa
il piano
ragazzi abbiamo preso la mappa ora
guardiamo subito quali sono gli
obiettivi temporali che mi guarda
[Musica]
ragazzi ecco qua la nuova mappa piano
dei nuovi costi ma soprattutto ci sono
dei vari indizi con degli oggetti ad
esempio qua veicolo sarebbe dove c'è la
nostra casa dice che dobbiamo trovare
una scatola rossa invece qua dobbiamo
trovare una pala forse dovremmo scappare
qualcosa
e qua nel campeggio una pila è questo
che cos'è vabbè ci pensiamo dopo
ora vediamo se riusciamo a trovare la
scatola rossa
[Musica]
eccola la scatola rosa
vediamo cosa c'è dentro
ma che cos'è un cavallino rosso delle
sagome per i vari cavallini proviamo
posizionare questo cavallino in una di
queste sagome avete visto può trovare
tutti e quattro i cavallini sicuramente
devo seguire gli indizi della massa
siamo già a buon punto abbiamo trovato
un cavallino finora rod non si è fatto
vedere aspettiamo con il prossimo inizio
proprio nota andare al campeggio litio
che troverò una pila andiamo alla
ricerca del campeggio la juve da una
tenda
sarà questo il campeggio questi c'è
anche la fila proprio trovato il
campeggio tra l'altro cavallino sarà un
berlino berlino puoi entrare dentro
questa tenda con me tentare la prima è
sempre il più coraggioso arrivo merlino
non ho anch'io
no non si mangia la pila berlino a cosa
servirà terza fila
vediamo un po cosa c'è dentro questa
tenda
berlino tu vedi qualcosa
ti stai sbagliando molto comodamente ma
ha chiesto mia cercare il cavallino
merlino
fuori spero che non mi ami a vista non
legato al senato è uscito proteggermi
con allaccio allontanato roth bravissimo
bernero almeno ora posso cercare
indisturbata qui ho trovato l'altro
cavallino il cavallino verde
andiamo subito a posizionarlo ok abbiamo
già due cavallini se ne mancano solo
altri due ora controlliamo bene nella
mappa qual è il prossimo luogo che
dobbiamo esplorare
[Musica]
noi vicino alla scatola rossa spero che
non rubi lo schema e l'altro cavallino
che ho per l'ex noto
no
per fortuna sta andando bene mettiamo la
vicina
[Musica]
malizia reca tornano indietro aiuto
ok qui è andato via
andiamo
così segniamo il prossimo cavalcato ecco
fatto ora che ci mancano solamente due
cavallini vediamo dove altro potremmo
andare qua c'è l'immagine di una pala
che ho visto prima vicino all'albero
proviamo tantane di qua e vediamo forse
dopo di sotterrare qualcosa
andiamo a vedere controlliamo non pensa
più vitale l'abbia messa sotto terra è
molto più probabile che l'abbia messo in
un congelatore per trasformarlo in un
gelato eccolo qua vedete una pala la
stessa della mappa è stata per fare devo
scavare e se devo scappare
dove devo scavare e truffate è l'acqua
andiamo meglio c'è un bastoncino
vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua
no è un normale bastoncino forse vuol
dire che devo scappare qui penso che
questo bastoncino qui voglia dire che
devo scappare proprio qui proviamo e
vediamo questo troveremo sotto terra
non c'è niente forse era una trappola
guardate c'è qualcosa un foglio berlino
potevi scalare tu con le tue zampe che
sei più bravo
vediamo cosa sia dentro questo figlio
il cavallino questa volta il quello
giallo
abbiamo già trovato tre cavallini forse
riusciremo davvero a salvare vitale
andiamo subito a posizionarlo ok eccoci
qua posizioniamo il cavallino giallo
manca solamente un cavallino vediamo
nella mappa o nell'altro inizio penso
che l'unica cosa che manchi sia questa
questa scatola inquietante non so cosa
voglia dire ma ora andiamo a cercarla
nel giardino continuiamo le esplorazioni
roth sta prendendo la parola
da coprendo il buco
ora ho scoperto che firmato una ditta
pallini corto di me vedevo rifugiare
partenza
la notizia nel corto forse sta andando
si sta avvicinando
no
dove qui
youtube
[Musica]
per un pelo sono riuscita a chiudere la
tenda giusto in tempo è rotto non è
riuscito aiuto dai virus sembra su via
io non voto più guardate non vedete
anche voi laggiù la scatola della mappa
sembra una più equa della dobbiamo
uscire dalla tenda e andare lì verso la
scatola dobbiamo essere molto cauti
per fortuna vincerò
ok via libera ieri ho mai visto
quest'anno scatola sembra proprio quella
della mappa ma cosa che può fare con
vogue buzzati
ma questa scatola parla come possibile
ma vabbè alla bocca mai abbassare
nuovamente
berlino c'è qualcuno là dentro e chi no
no no non faccio male
carino forse sì
dopo di che berlino non beccare potrebbe
esserci qualcuno qua dentro
ok grazie mille mostro della strada ti
lascio con berlino è il campo andiamo
subito a mettere in ultimo cavallino nel
nostro schema io avremmo vinto la
challenge e penso che farò qui o no ha
preso lo schema come faccio adesso aiuto
berlino
[Musica]
bravo berlino
[Applauso]
davvero davvero
[Musica]
sì ragazzi road è sparito perché sono
riuscita a posizionare tutti e quattro i
cavallini
ma dove sarà vitale non è ricomparso
forse era già stato trasformato in un
gelato in un cornetto in omaggio un
polipo in liuc scatola spero che non ci
sia un altro della dentro o tipo il
figlio di roth chi sei che cosa vuoi
grati e felici rosa barbie perché non si
il sito primo fuori dalla scatola perché
ero impressionato là dentro messo là
dentro surgelato per un cubetto di
ghiaccio
ecco perché non parla
siamo riusciti a vincere anche questa
challenge di ice cream 3
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete anche
ai scream 4 a 40 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche ice scream 4 e rod tornerà e ora
vi lasciamo qua quattro case linee su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione